Es ist 5 Uhr 15 in einem Bett
in einem Zimmer
in einem Haus
nördlich von Hannover.
Exakt zwei Minuten vor dem
Läuten des Weckers
fährt die biologische Atomuhr
Ursula von der Leyens
die Körpertemperatur auf
37,2 Grad Celsius hoch.
So beginnt der Arbeitstag einer
perfekt konstruierten Menschmaschine.
Beim Frühstück schneidet UvdL
allein mit der Schärfe ihrer Stimme
genau gleiche Stücke vom
korsischen Ziegenkäse ab
und plaziert sie flächendeckend
auf Knäckebrot-Rohlinge.
Noch beim optimalen Einspeicheln der
Bissen gilt der erste Gedanke des
Tages ihrer Hauptfeindin Kristina
Schröder. UvdLs Generation ist es
schließlich gewesen, die solche
halbgaren Frolleins wie Schröder
überhaupt in diese Position
hat aufsteigen lassen.
Egal ob Krippenplätze,
Mindestlohn oder Frauenquote:
Die vermaledeite Göre
aus dem Familienministerium -
ihrem alten Ministerium -
hatte sich stets gesträubt
und war bei Mutti petzen gegangen.
Es ist schließlich der Auftrag UvdLs,
die CDU in die Moderne zu
führen. Da möchte sie doch
sehr darum bitten, dass
BigMerkelMutti ihr wenigstens
Schröder vom Halse hält.
Mittlerweile ist es
5 Uhr 59 und 30 Sekunden geworden,
Menschmaschine UvdL öffnet
die Haustür und um
genau 6 Uhr schließt sich
der Schlag einer schwarzen
Dienstlimousine.
Für die 279 Kilometer
hat Ursula von der Leyen
ihrem Fahrer zwei Stunden
und 34 Minuten bewilligt,
keine Sekunde mehr. Während der
Fahrt formuliert UvdL
mehrere Handouts zu den
Themen Elterngeld,
Bildungsgutscheine, Hartz-IV-Reform
und die Förderung von diversen
zum Teil noch unbekannten Geschlechtern
in Führungspositionen.
UvdL speichert sämtliche
Positionspapiere auf ihrer
kopfeigenen Festplatte. Über
Blootooth liest ihr Smartphone
den Kopf aus und überträgt die
Daten an den Drucker im Ministerium.
Dank dieser Methode trifft
die Meinung der Ministerin
schon circa eine Stunde
vor ihr selbst dort ein.
Noch bevor das politische Berlin
seine erste Schrippe geschmiert hat,
stehen die kompletten Ansichten
Ursula von der Leyens im Netz
und müssen nicht erst durch
Diskussion mit so genannten Experten
eigens gebildet werden. Jetzt spricht
Ursula von der Leyen zum Fahrer:
"Wie weit noch, Steuermann?"
Der schaut nach vorn
und schaut in die Rund': "Noch
30 Minuten ... halbe Stund'."
Zeit für 29 Minuten Powernapping.
Das System UvdL schaltet auf Stand-by
und träumt von gegrillten
Familienministerinnen.